hello everyone welcome to the occasional
holiday special episode of the mindscape
podcast not really holiday special so
much is a year-end message for those of
you who are not here last year the basic
idea is that I try to do a podcast every
week except I take a couple of weeks off
for the holidays and in one of those
holiday weeks I'll try to at least put
something out there just to say thank
you for everyone listening no real
substance no real interview with anyone
no real deep thoughts but I'll chat a
little bit about the year things that
happened the state of the podcast that
kind of stuff so that's what this is
here we are holiday message I'm not
promising there'll be a holiday message
every year but this year I seem to have
the time for it so let's go
[Music]
2019 was the first full calendar year of
existence for the mindscape podcast just
started last year in 2018 so overall I
think it's going really really well I'm
happy with both the guests especially
most happy about those happy with the
audience listening fairly happy with my
own performance although I do think I
could do better you know I mean people
say good and bad things about one's
performance as a podcast host but I
really want to try to get better moving
beyond just asking questions that are
the obvious questions and try to get
better at asking questions that bring
something new out in each podcast the
the weird sort of dilemma here is that I
usually have people in the podcast who
have many many interesting things to say
and I feel like I gotta get to them
right you know there's so many things
that I don't want to just completely
miss out on so bringing up something
completely out of the blue might be
counterproductive it takes us off of the
path that I had in mind but I think I
gotta let go of that a little bit I
think I have to breathe a little bit and
let it be okay to have a conversation
that just rolls wherever it goes anyway
I do think it was a good year I think
that we had good guests and people are
always asking me what is my favorite
episode and of course that's like asking
what your favorite child is or your
favorite pet you can't talk about that
you can't really give an answer to that
even if it were true you would never
would never admit that you had a
favorite I do have a soft spot in my
heart for the less obvious podcasts I
mean when you have Kip Thorne or Roger
Penrose or Leonard Susskind on that's
you know the target audience for
mindscape many whom came from knowing
about me and knowing about my books and
knowing about physics but my favorite
ones as a genre are the ones that are
the least physics I mean the physics II
ones are great I'm not gonna stop doing
those physics is my one true love but
really I probably wouldn't be doing the
podcast at all if it was going to be
just physics I have a lot of physics in
my life already the podcast is a way for
me to get other things into my life and
it's been very very stimulating for me
personally intellectually sometimes I
will have people
as guests who I don't really know much
about before I looked them up to invite
them I do always want to know something
about them before I invite them but I
may never have heard of them before
someone suggests so you should invite
this person on and you know it's always
gonna be a risk right I do like to do
experiments I do like to try different
things so there's absolutely no
guarantee that every episode is going to
be a hit and I think that if that were a
guarantee then you're not experimenting
enough then you're not trying hard
enough then you're not getting out there
and doing things that are a little bit
outside the comfort zone enough so just
to mention - I light some of the
episodes that I really enjoyed there
were a little bit outside the beaten
path
the second episode of 2019 was Rae Burks
on the chemistry of murder which I
thought was just a lot of fun to get
really into the mind of someone who was
actually doing CSI type stuff is a weird
mix of science and you know real world
high stakes TV show kind of issues
Jessica Yellin talking about the
changing ways that we get our news was
definitely departure because it's much
more current event see but it has to do
with you know this thing that I care
about a lot which is how technology and
the internet and things like that are
changing the way we live our lives
getting the news is one thing that we do
but I think of that episode was a
wonderful example of how things that
have been happening in a certain way for
decades are changing in radical ways so
the point is not necessarily the
specifics of what's happening to the
news although that's also interesting
but as a paradigm as an example for how
technology is changing our lives
Adrian may or may I keep saying Maor but
she says her name is pronounced like the
political official so mayor Adrian Mayer
talked about God's and Roman and robots
in ancient mythology which I had never
heard of her or even the topic before
she came to give a talk here in LA and
that was just fascinating you know to
think about how people 2,000 3,000 years
ago were thinking about technology and
robots and things like that also back in
the ancient world
Edward Watts talked about the end of the
Roman Republic and the lessons for
democracy today we learned about the
Gracchi brothers who on the one hand you
know maybe you could argue they
trying to be good guys trying to you
know make things better for the lesser
well-off in their culture but they did
so in a way that kind of broke the rules
and that breaking the rules enabled
other people to break the rules and that
enabled the follow the Roman Republic
which is kind of a big deal
as usual lessons from history are not
straightforward for a present-day but
they're definitely there the episode
with Mark Devillier on hell the nature
of hell and where it came from and how
different traditions think about hell
that was definitely one of my favorites
I will even admit that that's something
that I didn't really know how it's gonna
be going in but just it's you know as
someone who does not believe that hell
really exists when you talk about Hell
and the stories behind it and how it
came to be you're talking about human
nature right you're talking about human
beings and how they think how they
conceptualize their place in the world
and even when they that's not what they
say they're doing they're revealing
something very very interesting and
important about who they are one of the
less listened to episodes which I
predicted was Matthew Lucy on the
pleasures of wine and I completely get
it if you just don't drink wine at all
then you're not interested in that
episode but there's an intellectual
issue here which is always why I am
interested in these topics right why do
certain things taste differently than
others what are the factors that go into
it why do some people like wine and why
do some people not so we tried in that
episode to give useful pointers about
what kinds of wine to buy and so forth
but again much more interesting for me
was the story the knowledge the
intellectual background the framework in
which all that comes out Astra Taylor
talking about democracy you know Astra
is sort of someone who could have become
an academic in a different life but
instead became a movie maker and a
documentarian and an activist so that's
a different angle than we usually get on
the nature of democracy which is
something I'm very interested in we're
gonna have more episodes about democracy
coming up so you know don't get tired of
that or don't be surprised when that
happens
Frank Lantz talking about games as a
game designer so not
theory from the math point of view but
the literal games you play on your
computer or even board games or things
like that what makes something a game
what makes a game good or less good
these you know these are again things
that illuminate the way human beings
think Lynne Kelly talking about memory
palaces in the ancient world that was
definitely one I was skeptical about
whether or not that would be interesting
but it is fascinating you know both for
again an individual kind of thought how
do you put something together that makes
you remember things in a slightly better
way but also what did ancient cultures
do when they were trying to remember
things could they have built massive
structures which worked for them as
memory palaces those of you who listen
to the episode know that Lynn thinks
that Stonehenge might be an example of
an ancient memory palace and then more
recently you know we had fun episodes
with a bunch of people will Wilkinson on
partisan polarization and the
urban-rural divide that's that's a good
that's a wonderful episode as a example
of a certain thing that happens because
will is a libertarian by political
nature he's voted for Republicans more
often than Democrats we talked a little
bit about modern politics but most of it
was not about you know who is Right who
is wrong it was about how people with
different political inclinations have
sorted themselves geographically what is
the reason for that what are the
implications for that again a very
straightforward intellectual exercise in
understanding how people behave yet
obviously you're gonna get a bunch of
people kvetching because it's politics
and they don't like the implicit
rejection of their political view
etcetera etc etc so sorry about that but
that's not going away either we're gonna
have episodes we're not gonna have you
know political candidates on or we're
not going to talk about pieces of
legislation or anything like that but
I'm absolutely going to be talking about
intellectual issues that have a bearing
on politics this idea that you know
politics is something that is inherently
contaminating and we should stay away
from it I think this is a terrible idea
I think that politics is just absolutely
crucial to everything it's a challenge
doing politics well is very very much a
challenge because it becomes so
emotional so personal so
tribal right you instantly want to know
is this person on my side or are they
against my side but that's not a reason
to not talk about the important
scholarly and intellectual questions
behind politics that is a reason to talk
about them more to talk about them
carefully to try to do as good a job as
you can and trying to figure out what's
really going on when we put aside the
emotions the tribes the my side versus
your side kind of point of view and then
recently we had two fun episodes one
with Grimes talking about music and
creativity which was you know much less
academic than most of our episodes as
you would guess and one with Stephen
Greenblatt talking about stories
Shakespeare Lucretia's Adam and Eve and
again that's that's that was an episode
where you know just listening as Stephen
Greenblatt talk is inherently
educational because he's one of the
world's super experts on Shakespeare and
the Renaissance and literary criticism
but I think that I is the interviewer
didn't do as good a job there as I could
have you know I wanted to hit certain
points and we got there but I didn't go
to as many we didn't go to as many
surprising places as I really wanted to
it's not Stevens fault in any way but
that's the kind of thing I want to get
better at as an interviewer so upcoming
year 2020 I have a bunch of podcasts
either already recorded or scheduled to
be recorded I mean I could probably with
the ones that I have on the schedule we
could probably go for the first three
months no problem and I'm not telling
you who they're gonna be but I have some
wonderful I think it's is exactly the
kind of mix that I want of well-known
names you will have heard of some names
you will have heard of but be surprised
there on this podcast and a bunch of
people who you have never heard of so of
course we'll see how it goes most of
them have not yet been recorded but I'm
looking forward to that otherwise sort
of end-of-the-year news I wish I had
more science news for you that still you
know spend what I spend most of my time
on is trying to move science forward
with my students and so forth but not so
much because of the podcast but because
of the book writing and and talking
about etc this was a slow year for
science also just because of random
timing things you know
did a lot of science but it didn't quite
turn into publishable papers so at the
beginning of next year there'll be what
looks like a burst of productivity but
it's actually just paying off from all
the work that got done this year in
cosmology in quantum mechanics of course
and I'm really finally trying to make
good on the promise I made to myself to
do more work to think more carefully
outside quantum mechanics and cosmology
and general relativity and field theory
and in areas like statistical mechanics
complexity theory philosophical issues
of causation and things like that
there's something I've threatened to
work on you know I have opinions about
it I've written about it a lot I have
one paper with Scott Aaronson on the
growth of complexity but you know I
haven't really dived into it very
seriously so as personally my
intellectual goal for 2020 is to make
that a lot more serious to get some
papers written about that to make some
contributions it's always this is the
problem I have with my own research
style is that I always change my field a
little bit and mostly you know I have
not been changing my field dramatically
right you know I started writing papers
when I was when I was a kid 20 years ago
or 30 years ago whatever it is in the
areas of field theory and gravity and
cosmology but within those areas I moved
around a little bit these days I'm doing
the opposite of what everyone else does
is that as I get older I move around
more so rather than sort of falling into
a certain comfortable zone where I just
do kind of the same thing and try to be
the world's expert at that I'm trying to
work on things I've never worked on
before which anyone will tell you is you
know a little bit tough it's fun right
it's exciting you learn new things I
feel like a student a little bit and
that's always interesting and exciting
but also fraught with danger because you
can you can say stupid things because
you're not an expert you know I don't
have an advisor telling me what is right
and what's wrong about these I do at
least have friends who know a lot about
these things so that's good so I'm
hoping I think that the story of 2018
for me if I had you know one thing that
was the big news in my life that year
was starting the podcast
the big news 2019 was writing the book
something deeply hidden and I think the
big news of 2020 is going to be some
science results that's my ambition
anyway that's my fingers crossed for
exactly that ask me again
a year from now when we do our 2020
holiday message so the big thing that I
did was write this book something deeply
hidden quantum worlds and the emergence
of space-time so I thought that in the
brief holiday message here I would just
dig in a little bit to the story behind
that I know that there's a lot of people
out there we're asking me not only about
quantum mechanics but about how do you
write a book what is the process of that
how do you get it published should you
write a book things like that so maybe
maybe I can just take this opportunity
to say some things about that you know I
think the book itself again was pretty
good you know no one who has ever
written a book thinks it's perfect by
any stretch of the imagination for those
of you who've read it you know the first
third of the book roughly is an intro to
quantum mechanics the second third is a
deep dive into issues around many worlds
as an interpretation and also some of
its alternatives and then the third
third the final third is speculations
about the emergence of space-time in the
role of quantum gravity and how many
worlds might help us with that so
probably that last third is the least
satisfying but it was almost inevitably
going to be the least satisfying because
it's not finished right I mean this is
just the difference between writing
about things we understand and things we
don't even though not everyone agrees
that many worlds is the correct theory
nor should they it's certainly true that
we've thought about the theory quite a
bit and we have a lot of knowledge and
the basic idea of what the theory says
is crystal clear there's still a lot of
questions to be answered about
connecting many worlds to the real world
and so there's still open research there
like people like myself and others are
still doing but it's easy to explain at
the popular book level what the issues
are what we've said what the theory says
whereas for quantum gravity and emergent
space-time the approach that I'm
advocating where you take a
quantum mechanics first approach
starting in Hilbert space not quantizing
some pre-existing classical theory and
seeing what happens this is this is
especially new and understudied approach
that even though I can say what we want
to do and I can give some hints as to
how it would come about it's much less
settled and mature than the other areas
so I thought it was important to put
that in the book to give and to let
people know to give them the impression
that all this discussion about the
foundations of quantum mechanics is not
just musty old history it's relevant to
the physics that is going on right now
but at the same time it's not quite as
satisfying a conclusion right you know
it's a it's like stay tuned for more
stuff going on and also you know even
the stuff that is going on is kind of
chaotic and we're not sure what the
basic ideas that will survive into the
future are so thanks to everyone who
bought the book there's still a couple
days left if you want to buy it as a
holiday present for the people on your
list but I certainly enjoyed writing and
I'm very glad that I wrote it it did for
one brief shining moment to make an
appearance on the New York Times
bestseller list so even though it was
like literally the last book on the list
and it was only there for one week
nevertheless we get to say forever that
it was a New York Times bestseller it's
a tough sell because you know a lot of
science books are released in the spring
or the winter and one reason for that is
that you're not up against the heavy
hitters the mouth and Gladwell's and
Stephen King's of the world who all
released their books in the fall because
they want that sweet sweet Christmas
business so my publisher thought that we
could do this one in September in the
fall I literally had my book come out
the same days Margaret Atwood's
new book the same week as Malcolm
Gladwell's new book so there's tough
competition in the airports and for
bookshelf space but we got on that list
at least at one time so thanks to
everyone who actually read the book so
how do you write a book like that you
know I think that this is I haven't seen
a lot of really useful explication of
this kind of thing I mean when you say
how do you write a book like that
there's two parts to it how do you as an
author sit
and actually write it and then how do
you get it published and I actually want
to talk more about the publishing thing
the writing thing you know everyone's
different and I know that that's an
unsatisfying thing to say
but it's nevertheless true I've said
this a million times before and I'll say
it again I have plenty of friends who
are professional writers who hate
writing books what they want to do is be
reporters and journalists and write
features and short articles and things
like that and then they can move on to
something else that that's a certain
style right whereas I am happiest
writing books and so I'm really really
lucky that way when it comes to writing
books cuz you know I feel like I need a
hundred thousand words to really get my
point across to really say things and
exactly the way I want to say them and
partly that's you know the kinds of
books that I write are in part my own
ideas not just reporting on ideas from
other people but in part it's because
you know I do have that that
predisposition to be an explainer of
things to try to understand things
really really well to spend time
thinking about them before I write them
so when it comes to my style of writing
it's very much deliberative and thinking
ahead right you know I think ahead I
have the idea for the book almost always
I start with the title and work my way
down you know Jennifer my wife who was a
professional writer has written just as
many books as me she'll start by writing
chapter seven and you know not know what
the title of the book is until much
later and it's just a very different
style and and and that style also works
very well but I got the title first then
I'm gonna get an outline just in two
chapters and then I'm gonna fill in
what's in the individual chapters and
sort of bullet point form and then I
will just tackle the chapters from
chapter 1 to chapter at the end right
and that's very what that's a certain
style and it works well for me and what
it means is that when I am writing
chapter 5 I at least know exactly what
was in the first four chapters because
they're already written and that's very
very helpful because I have an argument
that builds cumulatively and that makes
it difficult when it comes to having the
book be publicized you know a lot of
people say we want to excerpt from your
book and my books are difficult to
excerpt from it
actly because chapter 5 kind of depends
on chapter 4 right there's not a lot of
individual little stories there we did
it a little bit we did it this book I'll
talk about that a little bit but um
that's just how my books are so far
anyway I have ambitions to write all
sorts of different books I'm gonna get
in trouble because you know the
publishing industry once you've
established that you can publish things
write things sell things in a certain
mode they would like you to work in that
mode over and over again and so I'm
going to be ornery about that and say
nope I'm gonna write different kinds of
hooks over and over again one
parenthetically I threatened to do this
before it's becoming more serious I want
to write a textbook for undergraduate
physics majors on quantum mechanics I
think that that is something for which
the time has come and you know every
time I think about it I get excited so I
think that's a sign I should just sit
down and do it that's gonna be a
multi-year project probably but you know
it's a little bit tricky because in the
one hand I want to be new I want to you
know the whole reason to write a
textbook on something where there's
already 100 textbooks written is you
have an angle right you're doing
something a little bit different and my
angle is we need to talk about
entanglement and measurement and
decoherence and all the things I talk
about in my popular book but we don't
talk about them in most of our popular
quantum mechanics textbooks and these
issues of entanglement and and things
like that are crucially important for
modern quantum mechanics so it's not
just me it's not just crazy people who
care about the foundations of quantum
mechanics it's people who build quantum
computers or work on quantum
cryptography or quantum complexity or
things like that these are all
fundamentally based in the world of
entanglement and qubits and stuff like
that so not covering that in
undergraduate quantum books is is
terrible on the other hand you have to
have the instructors for courses
actually choose your book so if you put
a bunch of words in the table of
contents to your book that the potential
instructors don't recognize they will
never choose your book so you have to
write a book that keeps the old guard
happy but still introduces new ideas at
the same time I think that can be done
in this case and so that's something I
want to do anyway very very different
process
than writing a popular book so what do
you do when you ready to pop you the
book now these days you can of course
just self publish whatever you want and
I'm a huge believer in the benefit of
self-publishing something but not
necessarily a book-length
thing you know what I mean is write on a
blog or a journal or for a magazine or
something there's nothing like writing
to make yourself a better writer that
should be obvious but maybe it's not
obvious but I think it's absolutely true
you you do have a style but styles don't
just get imprinted from birth they
develop over time through actually
writing and seeing what works and seeing
what doesn't work and so forth not to
mention the fact that that's one way to
get people to read what you write and go
huh I'd be interested in a book that
that person should write but writing an
entire book and then self-publishing it
is a trickier thing you know writing a
book if you're gonna do at all a good
job writing a book it's an enormous
amount of work and so when people want
to sell books when people want to be on
the bestseller list when people want
others to read their books that's not
selfish or weird that's just you know
they think that they've done something
that is worth reading and they want as
many people to read it as possible I
mean of course it's also nice to get
people reading your book and to get paid
for it and all that stuff but
self-publishing these days is just a big
old casino right you can hit it big you
can be huge in self-published books but
also most of them you know there's a
longtail right most self-published books
nobody reads at all and it can be
frustrating to try to get a publisher
you know a standard trade press to
publish your book there's a lot more
rejections and there are acceptances but
I absolutely think it's worth the effort
and if that's what you're going to do
I've been lucky enough to work with one
publisher Dutton the entire time in fact
one editor Steven Morrow who is a great
guy and I'm very very glad to be
associated with him so that's sort of
the the goal that you should have if you
want to be a popular book writer if you
could
get a publisher and an editor that
actually knows you and cares about you
and sticks with you then that's good you
know the downside is you're not sort of
reselling your book as a competition
between many different publishers every
time you write one but being at a place
that you're comfortable with is probably
worth it so anyway I keep trying to get
to the following point the most most
most important thing you need if you
want to write a popular book is you need
an agent you need someone who is the
intermediary between you and the actual
publishers and as soon as you say this a
lot of people like you know their
shoulders droop and they become sad
because that sounds like an extra layer
of work and they just want to get their
stuff out there and they don't want to
worry about all this business and crap
but it's true the agent is enormous ly
important here the agent is you know the
one who makes your book a reality so you
shouldn't discount their importance and
you know there's a lot of reasons why
this is true the publishing houses won't
even listen to you like the grown-up
publishing house is the Simon Interest
errs and penguins and and random houses
of the world don't want to hear they
don't there's no pile of unsolicited
manuscripts sitting in the offices of
publishing houses publishing houses only
talk to agents now the exception there
is university presses right Princeton
University Press Cambridge University
Press Harvard MIT Oxford all these
places have their own presses they
publish books and there it's a different
model even they don't only publish
technical books or textbooks many of
these presses will publish popular level
books trade books as they're called in
the trade right they don't want to say
popular level so trade books and you can
do that without an agent they will
actually talk to you right they will
actually take a proposal from you and
and look at it and read it but the whole
model as I understand X I've never
actually done that except for my
textbook which is yet another model but
the whole model there is very different
they will sort of offer you royalties on
the book so you will write a book they
will publish it and they will give you a
certain percentage of every book they
sell whereas a trade publisher will give
you in advance they'll give you a pie
money and then you'll they will count
how many books you sell and there'll be
sort of virtual royalties so you'll sell
a number of books and they will count
how much your royalties would have been
for that book for that many copies and
then once you get to a certain point
where the amount that you would have
gotten equals your advance then they
actually start adding more money into
your pockets when when you get more than
your advance now in fact here's a secret
that almost never happens or at least
that rarely happens most books do not
earn back their advance the publishers
know this this is all priced into the
system and this is why getting advanced
is a big deep and advanced is a big deal
because the publishers have a vested
interest in selling enough books to make
the money back from the advance that
they gave you okay if you want to know
how big in advance is that's an
impossible question to answer you like
as a regular first-time author it will
be a five figure advance is my guess
right so that's just a coy way of saying
between ten thousand dollars and ninety
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars that's my guess but again you
know if you become famous for something
it could be bigger than that right so
that's there's it's not a very rational
algorithmic public transparent business
in any way it's very hard to find out
how much other people get for their
books or how much money people the the
whole industry is making or what the
best way making money is or any of that
the lesson though is the point of me
going into these details is you want as
big of an advance as you possibly can
even if you're just a wonderfully
selfless person who doesn't care about
making money at all and is only doing it
because your ideas and your thoughts and
your words are so important you want as
many people as possible to listen and to
read them you still want a big advance
because it's the big advances that
incentivize the publishing houses to
sell your book and now the the footnote
there is that the publishing houses
aren't necessarily good at selling your
book and again this is why I say that
there it's a kind of
irrational not very algorithmic business
because we think of Hollywood movies as
crap shoots right we think of you know
there's a big-budget movie maybe it
makes money maybe it doesn't but I
actually looked at this mark wise who
was one of my colleagues at Cal Tech he
and I and a graduate student actually
sat down to look at this we were
thinking of writing a paper about it we
never quite got around to it but do
Hollywood movies make money and is there
a way you know if you want to make money
making Hollywood movies should you make
big blockbusters you make a hundred
billion dollar movie or you should make
tiny movie should you make a hundred one
million dollar movies or ten ten million
dollar movies if you have a hundred
million to spend and the answer was it
doesn't matter the answer was that the
current arrangement seems completely
rational completely sensible and
efficient from an economic point of view
for Hollywood movies the amount you make
per dollar you spend on making a movie
is about the same at least it was when
we did this five or ten years ago four
hundred million dollar movies as it is
for 1 million dollar movies now the
variance is much bigger for the tiny
movies a tiny movie you spend a million
dollars making a movie you might make $0
you might make a hundred million dollars
in profit back but you also are making a
lot more of them right so you might
think well maybe if you make one big
movie you make more money but the risk
is bigger because you're only making one
and you know so we studied that as well
and the answer is no the risk is not
that much bigger
not only do bigger budget movies make
more money but they do so more
predictably than the small budget movies
the small budget movies make up for that
by you can do a lot of them and
hopefully you hit the lottery with one
of them and so the theory that we came
up with for why this is true is that a
lot of what makes people go see a movie
is the marketing Hollywood studios
especially the big ones can actually
pretty well know how many people are
gonna go see their movie ahead of time
and they will market it appropriately so
roughly speaking it's not that much of a
crapshoot you know as always very famous
celebrated bombs or success stories but
roughly speaking they know what they're
doing and they're you know
what they're gonna how much money
they're gonna make doing it I don't
think the publishing industry is that
way they often seem surprised at books
either doing well or not doing well and
so forth so by all means try to get the
biggest advance as you can and that
means getting an agent so how do you an
agent the agents unlike the publishing
houses they actually want you to solicit
them right that's why they're there
they're there to be the intermediaries
between you and the publishing houses so
they will listen to your pitches for a
popular level nonfiction book they do
not want to see a whole book a lot of
people especially academics they don't
want other people touching their stuff
so they want to write the whole book
first and then just plop it on the desk
of somebody and say here you know
publish this so no one in the industry
in the publishing industry actually
wants to work that way they want to see
a proposal and the proposal will be you
know a few pages of here's what my book
is it will mention what the other books
are that compete with it while trying to
make the case it is nevertheless unique
and special it will say you know how
many pages it will be all that crap and
also the proposal might be an outline of
the book it might even be sample
chapters but it won't be the whole book
and the reason why is because the agents
and the publishers and the editors who
work at the publishing houses think that
they have an idea of what makes a good
book and that idea might not be quite
the same as yours
so in this case it's kind of like a
little baby Hollywood I always use
Hollywood as my analogies they live in
LA and my friends work in Hollywood but
in real Hollywood you know directors and
screenwriters have you know it's very
hard to even pinpoint where their power
is because there's so many other fingers
stirring the pot studio executives and
producers and Finance ears and so forth
and special-effects teams and makeup
artists and whatever for writing a book
there's a little bit of that there
you're not alone not only are you
writing it but you have an agent you
have an editor and the editor has other
people at their publishing house the
marketing department etc there's a team
that cares about your book so the agents
don't actually want to see a finished
manuscript they want to see a proposal
well
fleshed out proposal that says that you
know that shows that you can write and
then you have a good idea and then they
will try to work with you to make it a
sellable proposal so cards on the table
time here I went to the internet and
found all this out and knew about it you
know what was it ten years ago or more
by now
and I I wanted to write a book so in the
early 2000s and at the time I figured
you know what is the most important
thing that I know something about that
is really interesting scientifically and
the answer I came up with was dark
energy and the accelerating universe
right so if we're thinking circa 2005
that was certainly a big deal the
acceleration of the universe had only
been discovered in 1998 and there hadn't
been a really good book written about it
there have been some books that
mentioned it but not really
central very good explanations wrote was
going on so I thought that was the
perfect thing so I wrote up a proposal
and I sent it around to I don't know a
dozen different agents and every single
one rejected me there you go that makes
you feel any better and roughly speaking
I probably repressed a lot of what they
actually said but you know the basic
idea was yeah this is kind of boring I
don't really see what the excitement
here is you know they knew that dark
energy or the accelerating universe was
exciting but even though there hadn't
been a lot of very popular books about
it it had been in the news so much that
it was hard for them to quite perceive
what was gonna be new and interesting
about my book so eventually I talked to
Tinka Matson at the Brockman agency who
is my current agent and she said you
know maybe this isn't the right topic
like what are you actually passionate
about right now forget about trying to
guess what the rest of the world needs
or once what do you care about and so I
said well you know I just wrote this
paper on the arrow of time that I think
is really really interesting and I think
that's an important issue that people
should care about both cosmologists with
PhDs and people on the street and so she
said that sounds interesting to me why
don't you write a proposal what about
that and so I said okay you know that
wasn't I didn't take much convincing
because I did think it was interesting
and that's how
my first trade book from eternity to
here got written and I'm sure every
published every agent does it
differently the way that mine does it is
you know there's there's a lot of
whipping into shape of the proposal so
you want to make it clear that you can
write again but you want to make it
clear that you're speaking a language
that people can understand and then
you're talking about issues that people
care about right you know a lot of
people and I noticed that even when it
comes to writing science papers people
like want to write something I and I ask
if someone else wrote that would you
read it and they say well I don't know
maybe not so why in the world would you
spend time writing it and hope that
other people read it if you wouldn't
read it yourself so the the importance
of making it clear that this is somehow
not just true stuff that you're writing
into your book but interesting and maybe
even vitally important for people to
read about is very very important so
there's a period of time where you're
just honing the proposal and trying to
make it as good as possible and during
that time your agent might you know
spread the word right this is where the
agents actually earn their keep you know
being an agent is it's a it's a weird
thing and if you're already a successful
author you will you can become resentful
of your agent because you're like
they're making you know 15% of what I
make and they're doing way less than 50%
of my work but the point is that without
them you wouldn't be making what you
make you wouldn't be making anywhere
near the advances that you are once
you're a successful author without a
really good agent so the agent if they
accept you oh by the way how do you find
an agent well you look on the internet
and you just type in literary agent and
and look people up it's a it's again a
crapshoot some people are accepting new
clients some people are not you never
know it's kind of like applying for jobs
or applying to grad schools you just got
to keep trying and you have to get used
to rejection and maybe eventually you
hit on the right person again the
relationship you have with your agent is
very very important because you you you
want to have a vision you only don't
like be buddies with them necessarily
but your vision for what your work is
going to be better match
your agents right if you want to write
serious scholarly tome and they want you
to write a weight-loss guide then you're
not going to be happy but probably they
wouldn't take you in the first place
anyway so yeah look online just Google
literary agents there are lists you know
they don't want to be hiding from you
they want you to propose to them so they
shouldn't be hard to find the other
thing to do if you think that well I
want an agent of a certain kind who
really understands me the other thing to
do is to look at other books that in
some way resemble your book that were
recent books and turned to the
acknowledgments where everyone always
thanks their agent so you can find out
who people's agents actually are pretty
easily and then just google them
individually but again everyone's need
for an agent is different so my agent
shouldn't be your agent shouldn't be
somebody else's agent you need someone
who can work with you successfully so
then how do they sell the book well
they're going to whisper into the ear of
the publishers right they're gonna say
well I don't have the pup the proposal
ready yet but I have this author who has
a really exciting new idea so even
before your proposal is finished they
might hook you up with conversations
with publishers with editors whether the
you know publishers and editors even
though they don't want to look at your
manuscripts other than through an agent
they do know that they there are authors
out there you know publishers and
editors will often knock on doors say
hey you should write a book and then
when the person says okay I'll write a
book the publishing writers will say now
go go get an agent and then they'll talk
to me about your book so the the agent
that you have will try to make people
interested in your book even before the
idea for the book is really fully
fleshed out and then once it is once
that proposal is out then the proposal
gets sent out and different agencies do
it differently but you know the most
straightforward thing is there's just an
auction so there's literally you know at
9:00 a.m. Eastern Time on this day we
are gonna start taking bids for this
book and you know just by email or by
phone they get bids saying you know we
want to give you a $50,000 advance or
you know we want to give you a $40,000
advance but we guarantee they'll be a
paperback and a hardback right so
there's all these little variations on
the theme or
give you a three-book deal who knows
what it will be so that negotiations go
on and then they declare a winner and
you do have a say in that
right you as the author if you have a
good age and duration will say okay I
think these are the top two bids and
maybe you know you want to choose
between them of course you might not get
a bit at all like let's be I don't want
to be unrealistic here this is a tough
gig getting a puppy the book published
at all is something where as I already
Illustrated rejection is the name of the
game more often than not so success is
not necessarily quick or easy but it can
happen so for the rest of the discussion
I'm going to assume that you've
succeeded in that
so you've so your agent has helped you
write the proposal they've spread it
around they've taken bids you've chosen
a publisher and then you can start
talking about the nitty-gritty of like
what's the deadline how many pages or
how many words is it going to be you
know everyone works in words here right
not in pages so as a reader you notice
pages but publishers notice the number
of words and in fact like for my first
book from eternity here which honestly
now I know was too big it was too
bloated I should have made it shorter it
doesn't look overly long if you look at
it on the bookshelf but if you open it
up the font is kind of tiny and the
margins are kind of tiny so they fit a
lot of words into the that number of
pages so a typical book you know my
books are roughly a hundred thousand
words the big ones from eternity here
and the big picture we're closer to 150
the other two were more like between 80
and 100 so that's a typical amount I
think you know my big books are pretty
big so an eighty thousand or a hundred
thousand word book is perfectly standard
I think for a popular level science book
and then you can start talking with your
new publisher about what the title is
going to be you know what the deadline
is etc so again publishers are very
different just like agents are very
different so your agents roughly
speaking their work is done now right
they got you the contract the one
exception to that is that sometimes you
and your publisher the roughly speaking
the publisher is the company and the
editor is the person at the company
you're working with Oh
forgot something sorry I got to go back
when your proposal goes out there into
the world and you want different
publishers to bid on it it really is a
publisher that is built bidding on it
it's a company that is bidding on it so
I skipped a step because I said you
might meet or chat with individual
editors but then they need to go back to
the publisher where they work and
convince their buddies they're at the
corporation that you are worth spending
money on that you are worth joining
their author list
so in some sense your personal editor
the person is gonna be editing your book
is actually an advocate for advocate for
you within that company and so what that
means among other things is that you
have to not only sell it to them but you
have to sell it to them in a way that
they can sell it to the other people at
the publishing house and so that's yet
another little hurdle you have to be
able to jump over anyway so once that is
is in motion the only other time when
your agent should step in is that if you
are if you have a difficulty a
disagreement with your editor so for
example the title right technically
speaking I'm not quite sure about the
legal status here but this is what
people have told me you know once you
sign that contract and you give them the
book they can put any title and any
cover on it they want like that's not
really your right to pick your own book
cover book title you can say I want the
title to be this but it's a negotiation
you want to work with your publisher to
make sure that they get a title that
everyone is happy with but I think that
they have the ultimate power so your
agent can be your advocate in that
negotiation if your editor or your
publisher is giving you a hard time
either about deadlines or style or title
or book cover or anything like that your
agents kind of like your lawyer and they
will go in or your enforcer and say like
you know especially if it's an agent
which has other clients that this
publishing house might want to keep
happy they will be on your side but
hopefully you don't have that you know
with with Stephen at Dutton my own
editor he's very very good he has his
ideas you know he's not a doormat he
says well I think this should be a good
title and so forth
and unlike many modern editors he
actually edits the book pretty carefully
so let's skip ahead to you know I get I
said I was not going to talk that much
about actually writing the book that's a
whole thing use Scrivener is my only
advice Scrivener is a wonderful little
piece of software that helps you
organize book length projects but you
will have a deadline hopefully you will
get things written hopefully you will
send individual chapters to your friends
or even your enemies to read over and
all four suggestions often they will
catch things that you might not have
caught but eventually you're gonna have
a manuscript that is shaping up so there
is a deadline and that's when you hand
in the final thing but the final thing
isn't anywhere near the final thing this
is the bad news right you have a
deadline and you're like okay now I get
to go have a piña colada on the beach or
something like that your editor will
read through your book hopefully you've
gotten other comments like I said from
friends and relatives etc and you've
thought about carefully about every word
and every sentence you've read it out
loud make sure that it sounds okay and
so forth and then your editor will read
it and your editor will come back with
comments and again this is very
different from editor to editor some
people take this responsibility very
seriously and are very helpful some
people a little slapdash about it but in
principle they will come back and say
well you know the second half of chapter
2 is a little slow maybe cut some things
maybe reorganize things how about this
new chapter title there's another
negotiation and it might be at the level
of them going through the manuscript
page by page with individual notes in
Microsoft Word everything has to be in
Microsoft Word by the way sorry about
that you can use Scrivener to write the
thing but then you outport output
everything into a Word file before you
give it to your publisher that's just
the industry there's not really nothing
you can do about that and then you know
you're gonna decide what to do with
those comments that you get but the
point is that you don't have a lot of
free time you don't have a lot of down
time even though you've been working
very hard to write the book you know my
graduate students know that you know a
book takes between a year and two years
to write very roughly speaking and for
most of that I'm it doesn't impact my
day job much at all I'm still you know
going to the office being a scientist
etc but for the look
that two or three months before the
deadline it begins to affect that a lot
and those last two months a month and a
half my grad students know not to expect
me in the office at all I mean I'm happy
to talk to them happy to you know move
science forward but roughly speaking my
focus is on finishing that book and then
it doesn't end because your editor comes
back with comments and you have to
respond to those comments they might
have another round of comments or they
might not and then it gets sent to a
copy editor right you might think that
there should be a step in there where
there's a fact checker but there are no
fact checkers for nonfiction books
articles that appear in magazines are
way more fact-checked than books are
roughly speaking you can say whatever
you want in the book no one's checking
your facts your editor and your copy
editor will check your grammar and if
they see something they think is
factually wrong they might note it but
it's not their job to find things that
are factually wrong it's certainly not
their job to check that factual claims
you make are actually true so this is a
weird thing if as a reader you have
you're saying well I see this particular
claim made in the New York Times or The
New Yorker or the Atlantic but I see
this other claim being made in this book
weirdly the magazine articles are more
reliable than the books are you can
really say whatever you want in the book
and this is why there's always stories
about publishing houses being
embarrassed by having to recall books by
authors that said things that turn out
to be either you know untrue or libelous
or stuff like that so over the
overwhelming majority of the
responsibility for making sure that your
book is factually correct is yours it's
not your publishers your publisher will
send it to a copy editor to try to get
the grammar right and different houses
have their different styles so my
publisher has a weird rule where like
after colons they've recapitalized the
letter sometimes I don't know why that
happens but I don't fight it you know at
this point you're exhausted and it's
only so much fighting you can do so the
copy editor goes through it you've got
to reread it again hopefully and at this
point you're not supposed to be making
major changes you're not supposed to get
the copy edited many
back and say oh I want to delete chapter
8 that would kind of be a disaster but
you could do it and then after the copy
of the manuscript is okay that goes to
the typesetter right and they make it
look pretty they make sure that you know
the chapters are laid out well and then
you get to read it and correct it one
more time you get the page proofs for
your book and if you you know you can
catch small mistakes if there's a
sentence that is wrong you can fix it if
there's a number that is wrong you can
fix it but there's certainly no
large-scale moving around of chapters or
even paragraphs really at that stage and
by the way if you have figures in your
book here's the bad news you are
responsible for those two like really
it's mostly your job this is a weird
thing I think many people don't realize
about writing books is how much of the
responsibility for what actually appears
in the book is totally the job of the
author so four figures either you make
the figures yourself or you get them
which means either you pay someone to
make good scientific illustrations which
can be very good or you get public
domain images or you get images that
have licenses on them and you get and
pay for the licenses and that can be
incredibly hard you know I've tried to
do it I've done it a couple times but
you know for the particle at the end of
the universe almost everything I did
either I drew myself or was public
domain there was one picture of glasha
Weinberg and Selam that is like a Getty
image so I had to pay a thousand dollars
just to get the license to use that
thing and it wasn't that important but
you need the picture of the people who
invented the electroweak theory in your
book about the Higgs boson so you pay
for that
so yeah the figures the footnotes all of
that stuff is your responsibility to get
right and you'll finally see sort of
where it is when you actually see those
page proofs so for the most recent book
on quantum mechanics you know whoever it
plays a small role in the book and
there's this one picture of Hugh Everett
that you always see one photograph of
him it looks kind of you know
conservative and repressed and and nerdy
but it's the one public domain image
that is out there and in fact ever it
was not in any way
conservative or repressed or nerdy he
lived kind of a libertine lifestyle and
he drank and smoked and died young in
the whole bit and so we found another
photograph of him that was much more
representative he's sort of leaning back
in his chair with his button untied and
you know martini on the desk next to him
and we couldn't get the rights for it
like they wanted to give us the rights
for it but figuring out who exactly had
the rights was something we did not get
done in time so he had the boring image
in our print in our book so I could have
gotten the right image if I had started
earlier on that process but this is just
one of those things when you're writing
a book that is just such you know
doesn't seem important at the time you
want to get it right when you're
explaining how the wavefunction branches
and decoherence not worry about rights
for that particular image but there you
go
and then finally okay it's been proof
read and copy edited and bla bla bla bla
and your work you're beginning to think
your work is done like what more could
they want to view you know the book is
is is ready to be published but in fact
it's still a long way from being
published you know just just getting you
the timeline right I said writing a book
can be between one and two years but the
time between when you hand it in and
when it appears in print is roughly
another year they don't move quickly
here like they moved really really
quickly for the particle at the end of
the universe because the Higgs boson had
been discovered and that was discovered
in July and I started writing the book
in January or February so I wrote the
book in enormous rush and then they
really rushed to get it out so we got it
out by November even though I handed it
in in July so that was that was like a
world record at least locally here for
getting a book out more often it will be
here before between when you hand it in
and when they ended it and then copy
edit it and then proofread it and then
typeset it and then they're gonna want
you to do little bits of publicity so
they're gonna want you to go on podcasts
obviously but also things like write
excerpts or write articles and again
this is a rich get richer kind of thing
right and if you want to know how to
write a book that gets on the bestseller
list first be a famous celebrity that's
the really the way to do it
working your way up just by writing
books and nothing else is really really
really hard it's not impossible people
do it but it's very very hard and I mean
I am NOT a famous celebrity but I do you
know get out there I have the podcast I
have the social media and everything and
the publishers love that stuff you know
they these days people include their
Twitter follower counts when they have
write their proposal for their book
right or you know their number of
YouTube subscribers whatever it is if
you can convince the publisher that you
already have a public profile
maybe it's an old-fashioned public
profile where you've written for
Scientific American and sky and
telescope a whole bunch of times but
whatever it is at this point in that
sort of lull between the proofreading
stage and the book actually coming out
they're gonna want you to pitch articles
to magazines to newspapers whatever and
again you might get rejected you might
say I want to be on your podcast or
whatever and people say no yeah I said
no like I feel very bad about this you
know I want people to volunteer
themselves to be on the podcast even
better when they volunteer somebody else
I'm much more willing to believe that
it's a sincere suggestion when people
says oh you need to have this other
person on your podcast but even if
someone says I would like to be on your
podcast I want to encourage that because
I can discover people that I might not
have found or even people who I know I
might not have thought that they would
be the right podcast guest and maybe
that puts the idea into my mind but the
flip side of that is that they need to
be okay with me saying no I actually am
way over subscribed with people who want
to be on the podcast that's he that's
the weird thing like you might have
thought that there is a worry when you
start a podcast that you run out of
guests but now guests are volunteering
themselves all the time and especially
you know because I'm a physicist I get
physicists volunteering themselves I've
had to say no to some really really good
physicists so I think would be good
podcast guests but I've had enough
physics here enough certain kind of
physics quantum mechanics etc so I want
to sprinkle the physicists within the
broader things that's my particular
choice anyway you will once again as a
book author be faced with rejection
because you're gonna want to get
yourself out
and sometimes it will work and sometimes
it will not and it's it's also very
stressful because you want to time
everything right like it's actually
really good to get people to pre-order
your book and that sounds weird because
you know it does if people buy your book
on Amazon let's say before it comes out
before the release date
that does affect where you are on the
amazon.com bestseller list so you can
see go to Amazon there'll be a page for
your book that appears like a few months
before it actually is released and they
will have a number there where you are
on the bestseller ranking list and it
might be 2 million to start and you work
your way up to two hundred thousand and
you're very happy before the book has
even come out so those are pre-orders
that are moving you up the bestseller
list before the book comes out and then
they won't count as actual sales until
that first week so once the book
actually gets sold all the pre-orders
are suddenly sales and what that means
is you can you can if all goes well get
a lot of sales that count towards your
first week by getting a lot of
pre-orders and that is what can
potentially get you noticed maybe get
you on the best seller list at all if
things are going really really well but
also get you noticed by book stores you
know book stores have to decide what
books to put in the front of the store a
lot of that is kind of corrupt a lot of
deciding what books goes on the table in
the front of the bookstore is because
publishers paid them to do that but not
all of it it depends on the bookstore or
some bookstores really do have people
working there who have their favorite
books and they need to there's a lot of
books that come out so they need to
notice books somehow also so getting a
lot of sales right away is an important
thing but you want all of that publicity
that you're doing this sort of magically
appear that first week when your book
comes out so that can be tiring even if
they don't send you on a book tour so
the idea of sending people on book tours
has become less popular lately you know
the Internet is a much better way like
I've I've been to places you know I've
been to book stores in the Midwest and
gotten literally five people to listen
to me to talk about my books and what is
the what is the reason why I'm there
doesn't seem very cost-effective being
on a radio show or being on a podcast is
a much cheaper way to reach a lot of
people so I'm at a level where they will
send me on a few talks that first week
so basically the first week when my book
appears zoom around the country giving
talks again to get as much buzz as can
be delivered in that first week of
selling books but that's it just not the
one week then if you get invited to give
popular talks or whatever you can always
plug your book and and very often what
you do is if you give a talk that is
accessible to the public you tell the
person organizing the talk to coordinate
with a local bookstore and the bookstore
will bring copies of your book and
that's how you get to to sign them at
the end of the at the end of the gig so
again this is also very exhausting I
mean I know there are people out there
who are extroverts
who like it who you know being up there
on stage is exhilarating and then
talking people at afterward really gets
them fired up and that is not my
personal experience I get exhausted by
doing this I mean I enjoy doing it and
get exhausted by it I think that's the
right way of saying it but then your
book is out and you have something a
physical artifact in your hand right oh
there's also like getting blurbs and
things like that that's kind of a mess
and again there's no algorithm for doing
that so who knows there's a weird thing
where the publishers think that the best
blurbs necessarily come from other
authors who have recently been on the
bestseller list I don't think that at
all I would much rather have a blurb
from a person who no one has ever heard
of but you know has some credentials
right professor of this Nobel
prize-winner or whatever who says really
good things about your book you can tell
when you get the blurbs coming in who
read the book and who didn't not every
blurb is created equal I think it's much
more important in my mind to have a
blurb that is sincere and and truly
enthusiastic about your book then one
that is by a person who was briefly on
the New York Times bestseller list a few
weeks ago but anyway now your book is
out you have the artifact in your hand
you can give it to your mom and dad or
your friends and you can give it away
you have a book party at your house
again you know the publisher is not
gonna pay for a book party but you can
invite your friends over and have some
wine or martinis or whatever whatever
use your favorite
auction and you can sign books for them
and it's really a lot of fun and then by
the time is two three weeks after the
book is published it's like a movie
right it's like now it's gone like now
all that work and people bought it and
now it's more or less disappeared
there's much less talk about the book a
month after it appears then there is the
day it appears it's it's it's kind of
interesting
of course there still is talk about it
you know I'm very lucky very fortunate
that people have cared about my books a
little bit and and still do talk about
them for better or for worse right
you really have to bite your tongue when
it comes to saying just read my book
there's nothing where it's really really
hard once you put all that work into
writing a book and explaining something
as clearly as possible and then someone
you know in the public forum on Twitter
or whatever asks you a question which
you've clearly answered in the book you
want to say just read my book but that's
not a good thing to say because think
about if someone said that to you you're
like I just asked you a question this
give me the answer to the question so
but after that you're gonna be a
published author you know you know some
some of the lines that will appear in
your obituary author of this in this
book I mean hopefully you'll be or
potentially you'll be the author of 50
books and then you know can't predict
which ones are gonna be the most famous
ones that will appear in your obituary
but the fact that you've written them
cannot be taken away from you and I
think it's an amazing you know I really
do enjoy it I think you can probably get
that impression even though there's a
lot of mess and and craziness that goes
along with the process there is
something about the job well done
about getting a book written that other
people enjoy and then you know ten years
later you'll get an email from someone
who said you know I read your book when
I was a kid and I got inspired and now
I'm about to enter my ph.d program to
become a PhD physicist and you realized
that little thing you did that you were
sweating over where to put the
semicolons in Scrivener or you know
arguing with the proofreader about an
em-dash it changed someone's life right
you know it really had an impact it
really inspired someone where you get
hate mail who knows I get hate mail too
but I'm very good at ignoring the hate
mail
and I'm very touched by the genuine
expressions of support and the
expressions that that people really
liked it and you never know you just
never know
you sell books and most of the people
who buy and read your book
you will never meet you will never talk
to you will never hear they might not
have liked it some of them might have
liked it you might never know so it's
those little bits those little tiny
communications that give you a hint that
maybe you really did have an impact and
I hope that something deeply hidden has
an impact like that it certainly has a
point of view about quantum mechanics
and the many-worlds interpretation maybe
twenty years from now when a bunch of
people who are now in high school have
read that book and suddenly these people
are young assistant professors in
physics departments maybe there'll be a
different attitude toward quantum
mechanics foundations of quantum
mechanics many worlds even if we
discover you know 10 years from now that
many worlds doesn't work we need do
something else the idea that trying very
hard to understand quantum mechanics is
a respectable one that should be done in
physics departments I think maybe you
know who knows that would be that would
be the best possible outcome of me
writing this book but at the end you
know you've written a book they can't
take that away from you you know they
can't say you've wasted your time
you've you've put in some thought put in
the effort done the best job you can put
some words on paper that now other
people can share and that's a really
good feeling just as it is a really good
feeling sharing these words over the air
these words said out loud so with that
happy holidays thank you so much for
listening to mindscape as you know you
can become a patreon supporter you know
sometimes people say well I have these
questions patreon supporters get asking
me anything episodes once a month except
during the holiday break but patreon
supporters get to ask me questions and I
answer almost every question these days
I think that might I don't know whether
that's gonna last
the AMA episodes are pushing three hours
sometimes now that it's pushing the
limits of my ability to talk if not my
patience but you know that's one way to
express support but again as I said over
and over again who cares if you're a
patreon supporter I
you anyway I love everyone who listens
to the podcast I think it's been a great
adventure we're gonna go to some new
places next year and I'm excited for
what's going to come so look forward to
it have a good holiday happy 2019 and a
happy beginning of 2020 and I'll see you
next year
[Music]
you
[Music]